[Music]
Khloe Kardashian has quite the little
Saturday it's excited the 33 year old
kicked things off by getting her roots
touched up by celeb hair guru Tracy
Cunningham Coco shared this snap on her
Instagram stories revealing that the
stylist flew all the way from LA to
Cleveland for her early morning
appointment I'm gonna figure it all out
she also wished her sister Courtney Zach
Scott Disick a happy 35th birthday Chloe
used the occasion to post this epic
screen grab from a 2009 episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians along
with the caption we came a long way at
the Lord be with you remember when I
slapped you
hours later Chlo shared this cryptic
message quote you can be a good person
with a beautiful spirit and still
possess the authority to tell someone
you got me up there's a million
different emotions that are going on in
my brain
plus the proud mama instagrams a brand
new pic of her daughter true Thompson
writing mommy's little love a sweet snap
comes two weeks after Chloe debuted her
daughter with Tristan Thompson on social
media happy one-month old Homer a source
recently told et that Chloe and Tristan
seemed to still be going strong
following his cheating scandal adding
quote as of now she's planning on being
in Cleveland for another month earlier
this week she revealed what surprises
are most about motherhood in a blog post
quote no matter how tired you are you
find this energy and patience for your
child
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]